hello everybody Welcome to the Meetup
now I'm looking forward to the uh Ted
again actually the last one of the
summer because when we do the next one
it will technically be fall whether
we'll feel like fall we will find out
but for now it will at least technically
be fall
so everyone's had a great August so far
we only have a few days left in the
month even
and I hope everyone's really excited as
we do this
so first things first like we always do
when we have the when we have the Meetup
in person I usually ask who is hiring
now I know not everyone can jump in and
say who's higher in fact no one could
actually say it on camera except for me
and I am hiring for mainly part-time
roles some full-time roles but data
scientists
um Linux admins sales people a little
bit of everything that's what I'm hiring
but if you're hiring and you're not on
camera
let us know by going to the NY hack our
slack in the job postings Channel if you
don't have NY hack our slack you can
find it at nyhackr.org and at the very
top there's like a little jumping
hashtag it's like actually jumping up
and down a little bit that hashtag takes
you to the slack and once you're in
there you can then post your jobs in the
job postings Channel
another thing that we can't all do
together unfortunately is eat pizza
together now I got my pizza this month
from a place called zazzies it's sort of
like a cross between like a Neapolitan
place and a New York Corner slice joint
it's a con it's a fun combo here's the
front we've got good cheese lock you can
see the charring on the bottom
so hope everyone else is enjoying their
pizza or their other food that they got
I know we can't be enjoying this
together but next month we'll we will be
both in prison and virtual and at least
the in-person attendees can enjoy for
everyone in their virtual land right now
hop into the chat either right here in
Zoom or in NY hack R and let us know
what you are eating if you're eating
anything and I certainly hope you are
speaking of chatting and slacking
because we can't ask questions directly
of the speaker because most people can't
be on camera if you have a question
please go to the NY hack our slack which
you can find at my hackard.org and there
is a channel called monthly Meetup chats
go in there and ask questions I'm sure
some of you will ask questions right
here on Zoom whether I get them on Zoom
or in my heck are at the end of the talk
I will collate them and ask the
questions of our speaker I you prefer
slack though because for whatever reason
I can't copy and paste out of the zoom
chat and I need to be able to keep a
running list of these so please please
please ask it in slack if at all
possible
we have an exciting few months coming up
we have the September Meetup will be
September 27th both in person and
virtual uh thank you to Microsoft for
hosting us there it will be Eli Miller
and the talk is going to be about
predicting the Taylor Swift Eros tour
setlist every concert she has a few I
think three songs that are chosen
differently for that particular show and
Eli will talk about how he's going to
predict that that'll be really fun
um it is in a smaller room at the
Microsoft Office so space will be
limited we will officially put that up
for RSVP soon but rscp as soon as you
can because it will be first come first
serve we are gonna have to limit the
space for this one
October we will have a meet up to be
announced a little bit later but we also
have the r in government conference
you'll see I'm actually wearing this
shirt right now these shirts make up a
large portion of my wardrobe let's be
honest here that takes place October
18th through 20th we'll have a day of
workshops on the 18th and the conference
itself on the 19th and 20th if you're a
member of this Meetup which you are
since you're here you can get a 20
discount with code NY hack r
and we will be giving away two free
tickets to the conference either in
person or virtual your choice after the
talk
if you want to get the tickets you go to
rstats.ai gov and you can find tickets
there and I see Nicole just posted that
in the zoom chat and in the NY hack our
Slack so we have a few exciting few
months coming up Beyond October we have
some speakers lined up but we don't
necessarily have space lined up so if
you'd like to speak we could find you a
month let me know you'd like to speak or
I like to volunteer you
if you have have space somewhere in the
city and would like to host the Meetup
let us know we have a few good hosts in
Microsoft and two Sigma in brainstation
and a few other spots but we always need
more because it's very hard to find
Space so if you have space available and
you would like to have
a few dozen data science nerds in your
space let us know because we're always
looking for a nice Rockstar places to go
to
so remember jobs chat and the slack and
the conference coming up
so with that I am very excited to
introduce our next speaker coming to us
from the UK so one of our long distance
speakers once again here to talk to us
about Arrow which I think we hope many
of us at least are very excited about
everyone please welcome Nick with Emoji
Applause
okay yeah so officially engineering
bigger data with arrow
um let's go
okay so um today I'm going to be talking
to you about a few different things
firstly um working with larger than
memory data in r with arrow then I'm
going to be talking to you about using
the dpli API with arrow and some tips
and tricks that can help make workflows
just a lot easier when doing this kind
of thing and I'm going to be talking to
you about the parquet file format and
how that can help you really get better
performance on bigger data sets and then
I'm going to go on to talk about data
set partitioning okay but before I go
into that um I've used this phrase
larger than memory data and but I wanted
to get an idea of what actually what
what does this mean larger than memory
okay so um I think probably most of us
that have tried playing around with
bigger data sets in our sometimes you
know you can load that entire data set
into your R session and just crash it
entirely and and that's all to do with
if the data set is bigger than the RAM
and your machine so I wanted to get an
idea of you know how much RAM on average
um does a computer have it was kind of
tricky to find this but I found a bit of
data on the steam website um this is
going to be skewed right because um
steam is where you can get you know
where people get games from and things
like that so people might have higher
specs but we can kind of conclude from
this and typically and your average
laptop has 16 gigabytes or less um than
that of ram okay
so um I'm going to show you an example
of working with one of these larger than
memory data sets with our own
so the data that I'm going to be using
this example is from the New York City
Taxi data set and it's a data set full
of information about taxi rides in New
York and the full data set goes all the
way back to 2009 and it's got data um
about things like how much was a taxi
fare how many people are in the taxi at
the time what was the pickup and
drop-off location and things like that
and this data is all available online
and if you want to get hold of it you
can either go to the site itself and The
Links at the bottom there or there's
some code that will be in the slides and
it's hosted on an S3 bucket and you can
download it with just a few lines of
code it's around 40 gigs in total okay
now I'm going to complain here um I kind
of worst out on doing a completely live
demo I did pre-record this and that's
only just because sometimes with zoom on
Linux it does weird things with my CPU
but I will be narrating this demo and I
promise you if you take the code and
test it out yourself and you'll get very
similar results okay
so let's let's work with a really really
big data set with arrow to show you how
it's done okay
so the first thing that I do then I'm
going to load the arrow package
okay
and I'm going to set up this data set so
I've created a variable called NYC taxi
and I'm using a function from Arrow
called open data set and I just point
that at the path and where the data is
stored on disk okay and so the first
thing that I want to do let's let's have
a look at the size of this data set so
how many rows of data are in it so I'll
run this and it will take a moment
because it's pretty sizable
okay so the results there that is 1.15
billion rows of data and I will admit
that before this I've probably only
worked with data sets in the kind of
order of tens of millions and so this is
pretty pretty chunky
okay so with arrow we can actually use
deeply functions and to analyze our data
so you don't have to learn a whole new
API
so say if you want to answer the
question then what percentage of Taxi
rides each year had more than one
passenger
um so I'm going to take that NYC taxi
object so that's just the data set that
I created and and then I'm going to
group that by year so again if you're
familiar with deep hire hopefully this
code should look kind of familiar with
you because it's using that same API
so anyway to answer that question
um I'm going to start off by creating a
variable called all trips and that'll
just count how many rows of data how
many taxi rides there were for that year
I'm going to create another column
called shared trips so that's going to
be the total of Taxi rides where the
passenger count is greater than one and
I'll check out any n a values because
we've always got them in kind of these
big live real life data sets
and once I've done that just to make it
a little bit more visibly kind of
officially pin like simple on the screen
I'm going to create a new variable
called percent shared and that is going
to be calculated by just taking the
number of share trips divided by the
total number of trips times it by 100 to
get a percentage and then finally call
collect and that'll pull that into
memory and rather than an arrow so
um I'm also going to time this to see
how long it takes to run this on this
1.15 billion rows of data so the package
Tick Tock and it's quite nice actually
you just put tick above the code talk
below it and then when you run that
chunk of code together it will time it
so let's have a look so yeah this will
take a moment because it's um quite a
bit of data
Okay so we've got the results so we've
got um those summaries for all the
different years of data and the percent
share column and that took 6.077 seconds
to run in all that data
okay so um yeah so that that's running
on quite a lot of data managed to do it
reasonably fast and that's all to do
with how kind of Arrow implements the
deeper API but runs on the Arrow back
end
um so let's jump into a little bit about
what is arrow and a little bit about the
background there and then we can jump
back into some more code examples
so if you go to the arrow website
um you'll see this description of Arrow
it's a multi-language toolbox for
Accelerated data interchange and
in-memory processing
so that's quite a mouthful
um so let's break that down and look at
it like one bit at a time
okay
so the first thing to know um I remember
actually when I first started working an
arrow I did find this confusing because
people use Arrow to refer to the overall
project and the specification and the r
package and these are all slightly
different things
so we'll start from the specification so
Apache Arrow arrow is a specification
and it defines how we represent
um table-like data sets in memory okay
so that's an important kind of starting
point how we think about that is just
specifying exactly how to do this
and it's defined in multiple languages
so in this diagram here we've got the
specification itself for how we
represent this data in memory and then
on that next row before that's just
showing that this specification has been
implemented in lots of different
languages so we've got C plus plus
JavaScript and rust on the diagram there
but there's loads of other
implementations so there's like C sharp
there's Java and there's probably others
that I'm not mentioning
but the one that we're really interested
in um for the purpose of kind of this
talk and generally at the moment is the
C plus plus implementation and the r
package the arrow r package has created
bindings for that so what that means is
you can use The Arrow C plus
implementation directly from R but
without having to know any C plus plus
and using the DPI API for the most part
to interact with that
and that C plus plus Library um if
you've heard of piaros that's the python
implementation of arrow that also
creates Bindings that same C plus plus
library and the same for the Ruby
implementation as well
so the idea behind arrow is it's about
accelerated data interchange and a
really important concept that I will
come back to later is the idea that
because we've got this standardized
in-memory format it prevents the need
for what's called serialization and
deserialization so rather than if we've
got some data say in R and then we want
to work with it in Python rather than
having to copy it backwards and forwards
in a format that both of those languages
can understand Arrow provides this
implementation that both of those can
understand
and serialization and deserialization
it's not necessarily a huge problem when
you're working with smaller data sets
but when you're working with larger data
sets that can be really computationally
expensive and take up a lot of resources
and that's what we're trying to avoid
here
so there's a lot in terms of how Arrow
Works um that basically allows it to do
things faster so traditionally
um tabular data um as in the past has
been represented in memory
um on a row basis so the each row of the
data is kind of in adjacent bits of
memory next to each other and one of the
features of Arrow is that it uses this
thing called the columnar former in
other words data in the same column is
stored together and that allows Arrow to
take advantage of the way that Modern
Hardware is designed to be able to speed
up how kind of data is retrieved
so anyway let's come back to the aror
package
um so I guess uh this is this this um
this slide is just from the RoR package
kind of read me
um so the question is what can you do
with the RR package so there's a few
different things you can do and you can
read and write data in a variety of
formats and so we've got things like
parquet format and there's Arrow formats
so you might have heard of this
previously as feather and that's now
been renamed as Arrow format
um it can work with csvs and it can also
work with Json
um so that's kind of one area of
functionality
it then also provides tooling for
actually analyzing these data so there's
some bits of it that work um for data
that's been pulled in memory but also
data that isn't in memory and data
that's stored on disk and the arrow
package provides an implementation of
the dpli API so we're not having to
learn a whole load of new syntax to be
able to work with arrow and there's also
functionality if you've got data stored
on the cloud so on S3 or Google Cloud
Storage you can work with that directly
from Arrow and there's going to be
implementation
um for Azure and but that's kind of
still in the works at the moment and
there's some other bits and pieces as
well but we're not going to talk about
those today
okay
so I'm going to elaborate a little bit
more about this idea of using the DPI
API in Arrow so
deeply package is designed in a way
where the functions the DPI of verbs
things like filter mutate Group by
um they've been written as S3 genetics
so what that means is that they can work
on one type of object but they can also
work on other types of objects if
methods are designed to defined for this
so in other words when you're working
um on a data frame or a table using D
player what happens is the DPI API stats
those functions mutate Group by Etc and
basically take that code and translate
it into something that the Deep higher
back end can work on to analyze that
data
now if you've used the package DB player
um that works with SQL databases but
again it's still using this DPI API so
you can use those same functions analyze
data that's on a database but without
having to kind of work with SQL and the
DB player package basically translates
um from the deeper API into something
that that SQL database can understand
and this is kind of how the arrow
package works so again it's taking that
deeply code transl package translates
that into something that The Arrow C
plus plus implementation can understand
and do all that work for you
okay
um so a really important concept
um when talking about kind of working
with arrow is the idea of data sets so I
think the best way to think of an arrow
data set is that it's similar to a
database connection so in other words it
knows where the data is but when you set
up an error data set nothing has been
pulled into memory yet and what happens
is when you run
um you know a DPI kind of pipeline it
only pulls things into memory when it
needs to and this is how we can work on
this larger than memory data so it uses
this idea of lazy evaluation in other
words it only runs the code to pull
things in memory when it needs to
so if I was to look at that NYC taxi
data um sorry NYC taxi object that I
created before so it's a narrow data set
object and if I was to take a look at
the preview of it it says it's a file
system data set it's made up of 122
parquet files and then it also prints
out the column names and the data types
of the different columns as well
now in terms of the D player pipeline
that I settled before so that was this
code here if I was to set that up
without calling collect at the end and
look at that object there this is an
arrow D player query object so it kind
of as I said before and this query is
being constructed but it's not been
evaluated yet nothing's been pulled into
memory and it's only when you call
collect it pulls data into the r session
so what happens is all of these analysis
analyzes can happen with the data and
it's only when we've got the subset that
we want that we put back into the r
session so we don't overload and crash
our R session with 40 gigs of data and
one billion rows of it
so what I wanted to do now is talk about
some tips for working with these large
data sets because I found for me
personally I've got quite a specific
workflow that I'll have when I'm working
with deep higher and I've just I just
need to modify it a little bit when I'm
working with arrow so let's say I've got
a task of I want to convert the TAXI
fares and the data set to pounds because
that's the currency I work with
um so I've got this little bit of D
player well Arrow defy code here
where I take my data set
I just want a couple of years of data so
I've put a filter on there and I think
the last time I checked this was the
exchange rate so to calculate the fair
amount in pounds I'm going to take the
fair amount column and multiply it by
0.79
and then I'm just gonna collect um just
going to select the actual rows of data
that I'm going to look at
so the first thing that I might want to
do
um on this analysis is use the enroll
function just see how many rows of data
that I've got so I'll do that here and I
find out I've got 139 million rows of
data so I may or may not want to pull
that into my R session
so I find the most useful thing for me
for working with these data sets that is
actually using the function head and
then collect just to preview those
results and see the first few rows and
without pulling everything into memory
once
so first pounds had men collect
okay so as I mentioned before the arrow
package provides bindings to the dply of
verbs and also it also provides bindings
to our functions so if you want to use
mutate and deeply to create a new column
and then you want to use a function to
create the values in that column
for that's working arrow we have to have
written the bindings for those
um at the time
um of writing this kind of these slides
I think we had bindings for 37d player
verbs and 211 are functions and so some
of those are base are some of those
those are Stringer and some of those are
lubridate so that's all there and in the
docs you can kind of skim through that
list and see what's there
okay but actually sometimes um we need
to think about like what happens when a
binding doesn't exist so we've got a lot
of stuff implemented but sometimes for
various reasons there are things that
aren't there
so if I've got this example here where
um my task is to find the first three
taxi rides in the data set in 2021 where
the distant is greater than 100 miles
so I've created this variable long ride
and that is the taxi data set
get a filter that I want the year 2021
and the trick distance greater than 100
and I'm just going to select the columns
that I want to work out work with now if
I take that and something that I might
do
um usually is okay I know there's a
deeply a function called slice and so
slice just returns a specific rows of
the data and and I'm just going to say
slice rows one to three and actually if
I run that we get this error so error in
use method slice no applicable method
for slice applied to an objective class
Arrow D5 query
so this is because slice is a tricky one
um
not to go into too much but basically
and the internals of our data sets this
idea of ordering doesn't quite work
because Harry is using different threads
to read different bits of the data set
and so we can't quite have um slice
there so what would I do here um in this
kind of analysis workflow head to the
docs so
um if you go to the dark so it's like
this page that I showed you before and
you'll see what isn't isn't implemented
and actually the function slice head is
implemented so sometimes it is just a
case of using a slightly different
function but that will get you pretty
much you know the same results for the
tasks that you're trying to achieve so
I've run this code and then we've got
those first three rows
and if we look at the error message
um okay it's not on that one actually
um another thing you can do is if you
know that the results that you're going
to pull back from Arrow aren't going to
be too big for your R session so you
could use nro as an example to see how
many rows of data
um an easier work around than in that
case will be then to call collect so
that will pull that data into your R
session and now you'll be working with a
tibble at that point and then you can
use those DPI functions so there I can
use slice and it gets us those results
back
okay
um so as I said there is a lot of the D5
API that is implemented and is fine but
there is one little slightly different
um thing with what are known as window
functions so um what are window
functions window functions are
calculations within groups so I'm going
to show you an example of something that
isn't a window function but then how
that will become a window function just
because I think this is quite it's a
slightly obscure bit of terminology to
be honest and but it is something that a
lot of people do use a lot
so if I want to calculate the average
taxi fare by year say just for a couple
of years 2021 to 21 22. then I could
take that data set
filter by the ears I want to look at
select just those two columns
and then if I group that by year and
then summarize that so I take create
this variable mean Fair which is the
average of the fair amount column and
collect that into memory then that is
absolutely no problem and I've got that
group summary so that works without no
problem at all but what if instead of
creating that summary I actually wanted
to append that to my original data set
so say if I wanted for every row my data
set to have the average taxi fare and
for that year
as an extra column in my data set then
that's known as a window function so
that's something um that isn't at
present implemented in Arrow so if I
group by year and then use mutate to add
that as another column
I'll get this Arrow window functions not
currently supported and arrow okay so we
need to find a slightly different way of
using these kind of functions
um and this is where duckdb um can come
in so doc DB is great it's for working
it's kind of a SQL based kind of
um database thing and you can use it for
working with kind of these large data
sets in a similar way to arrow and
there's overlap between duckdb and arrow
functionality so there's some things
Implement scenario not.db and some
things implemented inductively and not
Arrow
and one of the great things
um about drb is that it understands
aeroform and it understands how to work
with arrow tables and before I mentioned
that one of the things that we can do
with this Arrow format is if
implementation support it be able to
copy like be able to pass data between
different things without having to
serialize and deserialize that that data
and that's how this works actually with
a couple of functions in Arrow called
two.db and two Arrow so we can actually
take that Arrow deeply query that we've
got pass it over to DB run the code in
DB that is implemented narrow and then
pass that back in Arrow without having
to copy things back and forth
so here's an example of that previous
bit of code
um using.db so it's exactly the same as
before
but we've got two dot DB
then we call this mutate function
then we've got to Arrow to pass it back
to arrow and now that's worked and we've
got the results so we've got the rows of
data but with that means that on the end
there so that can be really helpful um I
find and there's a few other functions
as well
um that aren't yeah a thing in Arrow so
for example if you're used to working
with the tider functions pivot longer
and pivot wider you can also do this and
via.tp
okay
so um that was I guess a general
overview of kind of dply workflows with
arrow but actually if we're thinking at
a higher level if we've got really large
data sets what what are the different
things that we need to be thinking about
to be able to work with them efficiently
I'd say like the top one of the top
things in my list is parquet format
okay so poke is a file format and
parquet files are usually smaller than
the equivalency SV file and parquet is a
binary format in other words it's
designed to be computer readable not
human readable and so you can't just
open up parquet files say in notepad or
something like that to look at them but
the advantages of the parquet format is
that there are a load of different
optimizations that just make it so much
actually faster than working with csvs
so one of the things with parquet is
that it doesn't just store the data
itself it stores metadata about the data
so that's things like the data types um
I'm sure we've all had issues work well
or a lot of us at least have issues
where you've got a CSV file and you
might load it into I don't know um if
you're working with Excel I'm sorry but
um you know everything's a date right
um because csvs don't store the data
types so if something's reading a CSV
file it has to try to infer the data
type and we've got to hope it guesses it
right
um but with the parquet file it's got
the data type storage with the data so
we don't have to deal with that problem
it also stores metadata about the data
so it can have things like how many rows
are in that individual file so with
software like arrow and other software
what that can do is then read the
metadata rather than having to read in
all the data to perform these
calculations and know things about it so
that can be really useful for speeding
things up
parque is also inherently column
oriented
um and it also has this concept of Road
chunking which means that something
reading a parquet file can work on part
of the file at once and Skip some chunks
and and that really can just really help
things along so rather than just kind of
ramble at you about how cool parquet is
I thought actually let's get a code
example just to demonstrate the
difference
so
if we take that New York Taxi data set
from before so that was a parquet from a
data set and so what I've got in the
code here it's just right I've written
it to disk as a CSV data set so it's the
same data set but in CSV format so the
first thing
um I want to think about is how much how
much storage does it take up on disk so
if you remember from before the parquet
data set it was it was just under 40
gigabytes so the function I've I've got
here it just uses a few and basically
this function just calculates the total
file size
um of the files in a directory
so the total file size of the parquet
data set is 37.5 gigabytes
um but actually the equivalent CSV data
set is 158 gigabytes so it's absolutely
huge
um stored on disk in comparison and
there's a few different reasons for this
parquet has different kind of encoding
strategies built in it's got some fairly
clever things so if you've got a value
that's repeated a lot of times in a
column rather than repeating that value
it can just say Okay this value but like
100 times
um and a few different things like that
there's also a difference in analysis
speed
um so if I was to take so this is that
same example from before where we wanted
to basically count the percentage of
um taxi rides that had more than one
passenger
so I timed this earlier so in parquet
um I've got a slightly smaller subset
than before and I run that and that took
2.54 seconds to run that
so if I was to run the exact same
analysis on the CSV data set how long do
we think that will take
and the answer is 49.788 seconds and so
again the reason for this is there's a
few different things going on here but
just the optimizations in parquet make
it just so much faster to run these
complex analyzes
so um I wanted to give you an example of
parquet file metadata this is from the
parquet docs there's lots of stuff in
here and to be honest like I don't kind
of you know there's lots of bits that
aren't relevant but we've got different
things like kind of the number of rows
and the schema of the data so that's the
column types
um and column names and just lots of
different things that then we can use to
kind of optimize the reading of data
so the last kind of main topic around
speeding things up that I wanted to talk
to you about is partitioning
so when we've got these massive data
sets um you could have all of the data
stored in one huge file and you could
work with data like that and and that's
you know that that might be just how you
get the data and that's fine but one of
the ways that you can speed things up is
to use partitioning
so partitioning is when we store the
data in multiple files in different
directories and we actually use
directories representing columns in the
data so um in the image here we've got
the NYC taxi data set and I've just got
a little bit of a preview there so we've
got a folder that's actually called year
equals 2012 and then inside that there's
a folder for each of the months so month
equals one month equals two Etc and then
inside each of these folders then we've
got the parquet file
so that's just an extra kind of level of
optimization where now when we're doing
analysis in Arrow it can scan the
different um partitions and know we
don't even need to bother with certain
ones if we filter the data and by
certain variables
so again I thought it'd be good to do
some comparisons
um a question that people often I think
you know a reasonable question that
people ask once once you know they they
hear about the idea of partitioning then
it's all what variables in the data set
should we use for partitioning
so I think one of one of the most
straightforward bits of advice is to
Partition by data that you're going to
use in your analysis
so I've set up this comparison so the
original NYC taxi data set it was
partitioned by both year and month
and I've created a copy of it that just
partitions by year but not by month so
let's compare performance on the two of
those
so um that's that same analysis as
before I've added in an extra little bit
here where we want to group the results
by year and month just so we're using
both of those variables in our analysis
um so if I run this code this is again
working out the percentage of shared
trips when the data set has been
partitioned just by year but not month
so in other words we'll have to go into
each of those individual files and just
get the date of the month that we want
okay so that's taken 8.338 seconds and
then the original data set where we were
partitioned by both year and month and
not just year okay so that's taking 5.6
seconds so to be honest those are both
pretty fast but on a bigger data set or
one with less filtering and you'll get
more kind of pronounced differences
between the two of those
so partitioning can be a bit of a
strange one and people have described it
as an art and a science and there's a
few different things and I think the
most kind of useful bits of advice that
I've been given on this
so the first thing to consider is the
number of partitions is important so you
know you could take it to a ridiculous
level and say well what if I just have
one more of data per file and actually
that would slow things down because
Arrow has to read the metadata of every
single file and so that's going to add a
bit of kind of overhead there
um generally um you should avoid files
that are less than 20 megabytes or
bigger than two gigabytes and avoid more
than 10 000 files because just life is
not good at that point
um but generally partitioning on
variables that you're most likely to use
in filters so this can be I don't know I
feel like this can be quite simple if
you've got data where you're going to be
analyzing things by date
um but if you've got data we're actually
going to be using different groupings
then it sometimes it's it it's easier to
use a bit of trial and error and figure
out what is going to work for you and
your use case
okay so just to summarize um kind of
that kind of name bit so
um Arrow actually work with larger than
memory data directly from R using the D5
API
um storing files in parquet format and
will speed things up significantly and
and if you are using partitioning which
I'd recommend you should definitely
partition data based on your analysis
work shows workflows
late at night for me
so um I just want to wrap up actually by
um just kind of pointing out some useful
resources if you want to learn about
more about our or do more with arrow and
so in our docs we've got lots of
vignettes
um for performing all sorts of different
tasks with arrow and reference Pages
there as well
um there's also the arrow R cookbook um
so the docs you know the docs could be
great but um I think sometimes it can be
a bit dense if you just want to have a
very specific task that you want to do
so we've got a cookbook that's got
individual recipes for kind of
Performing one single thing so it will
tell you how to achieve that task
um a little bit of code and not too much
detail and then more detail further on
okay
there's also an arrow cheat sheet if you
want an overview of all the different
things that you can do just kind of in
one kind of easy to kind of see in in
one
um in one go then there is an arrow
cheat sheet
and also I just want to point out
actually as well the use our tutorial
from 2022 so this was taught by Danielle
Navarro and it gives a really
comprehensive overview of working with
arrow and um Daniel's got a really great
site actually that has a lot of kind of
text description of what kind of all the
things I mentioned but in a lot more
detail than this and so I'd recommend
that and I will say that arrow is a
fast-moving project so there's a few
things in there that have changed a
little bit since that was originally
taught so for example one of the things
that's mentioned is that the Deep hire a
cross function
um doesn't work in Arrow but it does now
but the majority of the content there is
up to date and and and works with
current Arrow
um another Resource as well and I've put
together this GitHub repo called awesome
arrow and I've just collected
um different resources together so kind
of whether that's talks or blog posts or
slides
um but yeah the last thing is you know
if you're interested like please please
get involved there's lots of different
ways to get involved with arrow so the
first thing is that like if you find
something isn't working for you
um or maybe you've got a feature that
you want to request that isn't
implemented or actually if you just got
a question about how to use Arrow please
please please come to the repo and open
up an issue
um like we're a project where it's a
totally valid thing if you're just not
sure about how to do something with
arrow and do feel free to open an issue
and we'll you know we'll try to get the
answer quickly it's probably the
quickest way I think to get in touch
with kind of the project maintainers and
we are kind of happy to help with those
um if you're interested in making you
know a pull request that's that's great
as well so I always say like with docs
the people that are best to write the
dots are not the people that work on the
package most of the time so if there's
something that doesn't make sense in the
docs or you think would be it could be
explained better we'd love pull requests
for those equally if you want to make a
pull request the cookbook or even even
to the code you know if there's an issue
open please please go ahead
um
yeah and I think yeah that was
everything so thank you
um I'll do a round of applause and give
you a golf clap and other people you
know you can clap how we see fit in the
chats well thank you very much for the
talk um before we get to questions say
our government conference you can still
get tickets for 20 off using code and my
hack R And for those of you that don't
know the r government conference is
about R and Friends uh so our python
Julia SQL
primarily in government whether that
means federal or state or local or
schools but also means public sector so
ngos and international governments and
uh Healthcare even so as general public
service and uh government of different
levels so please uh folks go hop on
rstats.ai gov and check it out you can
see previous year's videos at the same
address
so we have a few questions here
um so the first one is why doesn't end
row need to be collected but other
things do like when you call it Enron a
data set it gives you the answer
yeah and that's that's a good question
so with nro let me try to think now
about the specific implementation
details
um I think there's things like so
basically arrow is scanning the files in
that data set so when it scans the file
so for example with parquet it's already
got that information about the rows
there
um and it it just it it takes that kind
of metadata or whatever it's scanned and
uses that to calculate the rows so it's
it's quite a specific example with nro
compared to say all the calculations
okay
all right
um then all right when you go to duckdb
I saw that you're able to use D pliers
assuming uses DB player yeah can you
actually write SQL code
on the once it's inductive or even when
it's in arrogance but when you do two
duck DB can you write SQL code have that
executed and go then and back to Arrow
um
I think you know I've not tried that
myself
but I feel like maybe because when you
go to DB then you are operating on you
know a duck DB object so at that point
you can kind of do everything you would
induct DB
um I'm not sure about going back to
where I think that works but I'd have to
test out I'm not sure sorry
so I guess you're saying we'd use like
DBI to make the SQL queries on it
um to be honest I've really not played
with that so I'm not sure okay fair I do
think there is a way of deep plier to
pass through SQL if you're using DB
player there is a function it's like SQL
did someone talk about this earlier
today but I yeah it slipped out of my
memory okay well that would be uh
something that will haunt you now
you mentioned parquet Only Stores unique
values of data it's like the word pizza
was in there a thousand times you only
store it once is it doing like like a
SQL normalization like the fifth normal
form or whatever
um I think it's more to do with like the
kind of encoding that it's using
basically
um I don't know how to compare that with
normalization it's it's
I think I think it's basically this idea
that it it you know it can just say
right I've got this value this number of
times and I forget what the encoding
type is called now but it's a very
specific thing um
there's not a question but it's a
comment that just came in time of the
SQL DF package and that's a little bit
different than what's going on here so
SQL DF allows people to write SQL code
to query a data frame that's in memory
oh nice that's actually pretty cool
that's been around for
12 15 years or something it's been
around for a long time it's pretty cool
there's actually a newer function
written that acts a little bit
differently I forget what it's called
don't remember the name of it there's a
new pack so what SQL DF does it actually
pipes your data frame into a SQL like
data frame behind the scenes and shoves
it back in
there is a new package which actually
takes SQL and translates it to D player
verbs and runs that on a data frame so
there's some things like that yeah it is
isn't it yeah whatever you want to use
it'll work somewhere because somebody's
enabled it that's brilliant yeah there's
a lot of stuff here it's really cool
nice
all right um when Arrow writes data sets
to csvs and you do a grouping
it the grouping columns B don't get rid
into the CSV file because they're in the
folder structure is there a way to force
that to put the columns in the csvs
anyway
um I would need to double check that I
don't know if the top of my head like I
don't know if it works slightly
differently if you use the hive style
um directory so the hive style is just
when you've got the
um the column name equals and then the
value rather than just um
I don't think that's default with it
sorry I'd have to
hey but if somebody wants to open up an
issue and then I can totally follow that
up and I will get an answer to that
question I don't know off the top of my
head sorry right now if it doesn't
because I'm putting in their future
requests personally okay good do it
please
can you do joins of Arrow yes you can
yeah so we've got
I think we've got pretty much most of
the typical kind of joins implemented
Arrow I think the only thing to be aware
of is that when you're doing joins in
Arrow um it's worth looking into the
concept of schemas because when you're
converting when Arrow converts data say
if you're say if you've got an error
data set and you're joining to a table
that you've got or something you've got
to make sure that the join key in of the
column that you're joining on has got
the same kind of Arrow data type
um I can kind of send more information
about that because it's more than a kind
of woman explanation but yeah and if
you're doing an arrow table join to an
arrow table same idea right yes exactly
it's going to be the same data type of
the join key yeah
what if one is an integer and one is a
numeric does that work automatically or
is that still a problem
um no because numeric is converted into
I think
uh as well in in into
um double or flow so what you'd have to
do is just manually set the kind of the
data type of those of the column to be
the same otherwise that can lead you to
issues yeah okay so even though so an
integer and a character you'd have to
manually convert integer to a numeric
first all right yeah it's all to do with
um the idea that Arrow's got a I guess a
richer a wider kind of list of data
types than R itself so a lot of the time
when you're converting things between R
and arrow out of the arrow packages all
the work for you and automatically
converts it and and that that will work
fine in most cases but it's just
sometimes unjoins that can trip you up
and yeah
are factors represented in Arrow data
sets yes we've got the dictionary type
in Arrow um and depending on whether you
kind of like specified that as the you
know that data type when you're reading
in or not and but yeah you can use
dictionary type is is roughly equivalent
to factors yeah
okay cool
um
this one's from me
actually this before so if I did I
apologize
um if you open a data set in like a
markdown chunk and using caching can you
use that open data set in a different
chunk later on
when you're knitting ah so yeah so
actually you mentioned this the other
day and you promised you'd open an issue
on the repo and you haven't yet so I'm
quite sad about that but um
you know what I came across this myself
when I was writing in the slides
um for this and got a bit frustrated
with it I think the problem with that is
an arrow object it's not quite the same
as say when you've got like a data frame
or a table and it can't just be kind of
like written it an arrow object in R
it's it's an environment it's an R6
object and I think the short answer is
you can use it between different chunks
um that that does work because that did
work when I compiled the slides for this
today but if you've got caching enabled
in your quarto document then things go
wrong because it can't actually cache
those objects because they're kind of in
Arrow memory and just have a pointer to
that so the caching is is what makes it
go wrong I think
so follow-up question with the same
issue if you would there be a similar
issue if you're using targets and you
try to make an open data set one of the
targets and then use it later on
um I'm not sure with that um I'd have to
I I imagine it might
um but yeah I'd have to follow up on
that one
then I guess follow-up follow-up
may can we serialize the open data set
somehow
um how do you mean what do you mean by
that then I don't know basically like
somehow like it knows like if you can
serialize it then like you write to disk
what it's pointing to that way when you
pull it from disk in the cache like a
special type of serialization it knows
hey I was pointing to these sets of
folders over here
I guess
not really I guess what you'd want to do
is create a variable that either has the
list of files that are in your deck
because when you open a data set you can
either give it a list of files or you
can give it a directory and then it'll
scan that directory so if you were to
store the name of the directory or the
list of files to a variable then you
could serialize the variable that's just
you know a character and Vector
containing those but the data set object
data set object itself it wouldn't I
guess it wouldn't really make sense to
serialize because it's a little bit
saying can you serialize a database
connection object and I I don't think
you can right no
and so in full disclosure the way I've
done this in the past the first hacky
way I did it was
um in my markdown chunks anytime I was
going to use that data set I'd have a
line creating it in each chunk and like
say Echo equals negative one and that
would get rid of it and it was horrible
horrible and I think at one point I did
but I don't remember where I wrote like
a Knitter hook that would for a certain
type of Chunk type it automatically
create the connection to the data to
arrow and open the data set not as bad
as doing it manually but still not great
yeah oh you should have like opened
Edition with the repo and we could have
done a lot work yeah yeah
in essence I don't remember what it
would I do open the issue
yeah yeah all good yeah yeah good luck
with that okay
um all right
let's say you have a bunch of RK files
like every day you're getting new data
doing it getting putting in can you
append the new data to existing parquet
and if not what do you do
um I don't think you can append to
existing parquet I think that's
um I have seen a ticket open related to
that but I'd say right to a new parquet
file
okay and I guess if you're working with
kind of partition data then you know
you've got a data set that's made of
multiple parquet files anyway so it's
you know it's probably no issue to do
that yeah I guess as long as you I
wonder if let's say the new data has a
bit of a do like if you put them it's
hard for me to describe this but and one
of the concern is that you have some new
data but some old data and you write to
the same folder what happens to the
existing let's say you're partitioning
by date you get a new date of the
original date does that override the old
date 4K file does it what happens there
um I think you want to override it but
there is a setting actually it's one of
the kind of more advanced settings but
there is a setting where you can specify
whether you overwrite existing files or
not
um or causing like end up with an error
with that I could find that saying um
somewhere in the docks um okay but yeah
it's possible to kind of manually
control that yeah all right
um
so I'm not sure this is your field or
not but what is the state of geodata in
Arrow
um and like and can we use like the SF
functions on an arrow table if it has a
geometry column oh do you know I really
should know this because my colleague
Joey like Works in a lot of this stuff
and and I feel terrible now that I can't
describe the stuff that he and other
people are working on really well but
I'm I'm not super familiar with the Jr
stuff sorry
there is lots of geo-related
functionality
um and I would recommend just looking up
Joey Donington
um and he's not the only one but he's
the person that I know and then that
that will lead to that work
I guess we need to get Dewey to speak
soon then right yeah definitely so Dewey
if you're watching this live or
recording you're UPS everybody
all right so can you comment on where
polars fits into all this
um well I know obviously you can get
kind of like similar kind of things with
polars in terms of working and kind of
large data sets I know
I know there's a there's an r package
related to kind of you know working with
that from RR
um I think it's it's I I don't comment
about other projects I think there's a
lot of tricky things at the moment just
kind of getting rust packages on cran is
tricky and it's new and there's lots of
difficulties around that but Polaris is
great as well like you know there's a
lot of kind of similar functionality in
there
um so yeah so I guess from an R user or
even a python user because I know polars
is richer and is more wide adopted in
Python because they don't have this
great D polar error integration
um
like what is it like a competitor to
Arrow G player or what is it
um I don't know it's it's hard to place
things right because different kind of
these different packages have different
kind of functionality to be honest I
haven't explored its full functionality
like I think that somebody has I think
there is a d player API package for that
somewhere there is some functionality
for that
I think so yeah I need to
there's just there's so many different
packages at the moment that are doing
kind of a lot around this it's hard to
keep up I think
um let me see a comment here um it says
there's apparently a package called
parquetize which has a function called
arcade ties which converts large SAS and
stata files to parquet that sounds
really cool yeah that's cool actually
I've seen that package and it kind of
wraps around um like a lot of kind of
the arrow functionality but like has a
slightly different convenience functions
for kind of more kind of it it wraps
around more of the workflow so
um but I didn't know it worked with SAS
and stata files that's pretty cool yeah
and I wonder if that um is sometimes
hard to get data out of postgres or SQL
Server into parquet so I wonder if
there's something similar in the past
I've had to use like dot DB to rip it
out of postgres quickly into a parquet
file it'd be really cool like that that
goes straight especially SQL Server
since so much of the corporate world is
in SQL Server yeah I know it's not
that's not your area but this was a cool
comment there
um
yeah and then I think
I'll give everyone one last chance to
ask questions here and see if there's
anything else if anyone knows anything
else they want to ask here about Arrow
or about anything else
um if I'll give a few announcements I'll
guess one announcement in the meantime
remember folks September 27th in person
and virtual we'll have our next Meetup
predicting Taylor Swift songs that will
be really really cool that's Eli Miller
is going to do that and then again if
you have space let us know and have the
space Oh there's a question is your code
on git for the presentation I presume
yes it is yeah I've got it all in a repo
and I've sent it to Nicole who um I
think and essentially get that sent out
so um yeah all the code that you need to
replicate any of the stuff that I've
shown today is all in that presentation
in the repo
all right wonderful all right uh then
I'll put one more question to you
closing out what do you see the future
of arrow in the r Community being over
the next 12 months let's say oh that's a
good question do you know what it's a
tricky one to figure out because there's
just been so many bits and pieces going
on
um I think we've got to a point where a
lot of our kind of deeply bindings are
pretty stable now
um you know and anytime things update up
date and deeply we do try to kind of
then pull that functionality kind of
into our own
um I mean I'd love to see we've again
we've got a lot of stringer and Labor
Day kind of bindings I you know I'd love
to see more of those
um to feel like the little bits and
pieces of the gaps that we don't have
um the Azure stuff is quite interesting
so some people are working on being able
to work directly with data and Azure so
that's going to be I'd be really excited
to see more more Cloud stuff done
basically
um
and other than that I've had some
personal projects I've been working on
just things like kind of reshaping our
docs just to make things a little bit
more approachable
um so lots of lots of little bits and
pieces like that going on at the moment
I do believe I asked either Neil or
Jonathan to support Azure like a year
ago so I'm very excited that will be
happening nice
yeah
all right great well I think that is
everything I want to say thank you very
much for this talk I think everyone
should be using Arrow more if they're
not using it already I'm a big fan of it
um and everyone else remember next month
in person of virtual and we have the our
gov conference coming up and if anyone
ever wants to give a talk let me know
that's how these things work so a big
round of applause to Nick everybody
thank you very much for being here yeah
thanks for inviting me it's been really
great cheers great have a good night
everybody